thousands of unlv students returning to
campus for the spring semester despite
the recent spike in cases and no vaccine
mandate most really happy to be back in
college joe mohler spoke to some
students today he's live on campus with
what they had to say they're college
kids joe they want to go back
brian you may remember last semester
there was that vaccine mandate in place
well students came back here for the
spring semester and there is no mandate
today we caught up with students to talk
about it
feels good while campus had plenty of
people walking around feels good to get
out of the house honestly there are
still less people here with 40 percent
of the classes going online despite the
spike in cases a vaccine mandate that
was in place for students in the fall
came to an end cayenne diaries does not
mind me and my family got the vaccine so
i'm
good on all that if no people don't want
to get then it's fine it's up to them
zoya allred says students who did not
get classes before now can causing a
little difficulty during registration
once the mandate was like you didn't
have to get it anymore
all the classes were full the vaccine
mandate is still in place for staff
there's always going to be risk
infectious disease expert and professor
brian labus was back on campus in a
virtual meeting tuesday as well i'm
willing to teach in class it's there's a
risk there there's always going to be a
risk but by handling things
appropriately with everyone vaccinated
wearing masks doing all those things we
can hopefully mitigate the risk most
students feel comfortable one of my
professors already threatened us that if
we don't wear a mask during an exam or
like we don't wear it in his class he
will kick us at like by the second time
he warns us laura sanchez would like
another mandate they're starting to get
a bit more strict again because of the
rising public cases but i don't really
know what's to come
now back out here live just last week
the board of regents sent a letter to
lawmakers pushing for another vaccine
mandate to be put in place now it is up
to the board of health there is no word
if or when that will happen reporting
live on unlv this evening joe mohler
live local now